voilà nuit les l'heracles jouit ici ici
ici énorme énorme
nous sommes à paris dans le 20e
arrondissement
la cités de logements sociaux python
duvernois en bord de périphériques est
infesté par les nuisibles 2000 le qatari
subissent depuis des années la présence
de punaises de lit et de cafards les
souris loge dans les murs et courent
dans les appartements les rats creusent
des galeries et monte sur les balcons
les murs des bâtiments construits à
partir des années 50 sont rongés de
moisissures les habitants au bord des
larmes racontent leur combat au
quotidien contre les punaises de lit les
nuit dans leur voiture avec un bébé pour
leur échapper leur vie enfermés dans des
sacs plastiques de nombreux enfants
souffrent d'asthme à cause de la
pollution des murs et du périphérique
une vie d'enfer pour les résidents j'ai
toujours à venthône ils m'ont péril ans
il a une assistance respiratoire
parce qu'elle cause de la pollution et
ben voilà il s'est il arrive plus à
respirer
il étouffe l'eau qui coulait du toit
dégoulinait dans mon dans ma cuisine
dans mon salon
mon appartement est devenue l'eldorado
des souris du rez de chaussée jusqu'en
haut il veut plus partis sont dans les
murs ils sont dans les plafonds
j'aime montrer les murs qui sont abîmés
les souris que j'ai attrapé avec près de
deux cols avec plein de ce qu'est ce que
la rien ne change il avait le fruit le
plus mais je ne crois pas donc en nous
on mange on fait avec le sourire ça fait
des années que je fais une demande
d'aidé change
nous attendait n'a pas d'appartement
vous avez de la chance vous avez un
appartement
si vous n'êtes pas contents allez dans
le privé je dors pas c'est un peu plus
ce quartier est engagé dans une
réhabilitation dans le cadre du grand
plan de rénovation urbaine nationale
ainsi plus de 300 logements sur 650 dans
les bars seront détruits un parc de 3
hectares et de vastes équipements
sportifs seront créés un superbe projet
qui sera finalisé en 2026 mais de
nombreux habitants ne peuvent plus
supporter leurs conditions de vie l'élu
du 20e arrondissement danielle simonnet
qui se mobilisent pour la cité nous en
parle
les conditions de vie sont juste
insupportable au dernier conseil de
paris moi j'avais soumis un voeu pour
demander à ce qu'il y ait fait parler sa
technique du logement un état des lieux
d'insalubrité ils ont refusé
si vous faites un état des lieux de
l'insalubrité et que c'est confirmé
aussi par la préfecture à son volant
s'est immédiatement que tout le monde
doit être logé et tous ne veulent pas et
qu'ils estiment que comme un projet qui
est déjà signée actes et les gens m'ont
qu'attendent les habitants n'en peuvent
plus ils veulent leur logement
maintenant contacter la ville de paris
n'a pas répondu à nos sollicitations
mais le bailleur social la régie
immobilière de la ville de paris la rivp
mise en cause par les habitants explique
être intervenue à de multiples reprises
une consultation a été mise en place
pour identifier les problèmes de tous
les habitants en vue de les résoudre
son directeur général serge compta
promet des résultats nous allons mettre
les commandeurs les bouchées doubles en
matière de gestion de ce quartier ont
une liaison avec la ville de paris n'a
mis un dispositif ont fait en place
l'intervenant techniques sur ces
problèmes de nuisibles avec l'idée de
traiter la totalité des problèmes mais
on a mis en place à la fois la démarche
technique la démarche de concertation et
les locataires et nous avons ouvert tous
les crédits
nous sommes vraiment mobilisé le
directeur général s'y impliquer
personnellement la ligne de crédit
suffisante pour répondre à toutes les
demandes et nous traiterons jusqu'à une
obligation de
résultat il explique aussi que la phase
de relogement à démarrer mais la faible
rotation dans le parc de logements
sociaux et la forte demande limite la
proposition à dix ou quinze logements
par mois 300 logements doivent encore
être trouvé un rythme jugé beaucoup trop
faible par les habitants qui se
mobilisent depuis septembre dernier pour
vivre enfin dans un logement sain